- I just wish that you
guys could smell this
because this smells really,
really good. (sniffing)
(air exhaling)
(joyful music)
Hey, what's up? My name is Tway
and welcome to a special holiday
edition of Making It Big,
the show where my friends challenge me
to make their favorite foods big.
Now you might notice
that my table is a little
bit weird and curved.
That's because we are
shooting everything in VR.
You can watch the full VR episode
with a Meta Quest two in Mega Tasty.
That's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon Worlds or on Meta Quest TV.
Today I have a superstar in the house.
I think she's here.
Hi, friend, are you here?
- I am.
- Hi!
You guys it is-
- Hello, my love.
- I'm gonna set this down.
- Thuy.
- Welcome to my kitchen. Happy holidays.
- Thank you for having me.
This is like a dream come
true for me right now.
- Thanks for being here.
Okay.
- I'm so excited.
- Well, I'm so nervous.
- I'm nervous too.
But you what-
- Why are you nervous?
- Because I have something
very special here.
- Okay.
- And very dear.
- Dang.
- And I'm excited
for you to see and uncover what this is.
- Okay, let's see what it is.
- Here we go, everybody.
(dazzling music)
Little Debbie's Christmas cake.
(Tway laughs)
(bells jingling)
- So I've never
(Thuy laughs)
had this before.
Can I kind of like take a look
at what's inside-
- Yes,
I want to smell it too. (sniffs)
(Tway laughs)
- Nostalgia.
(crowd cheering)
- Well you want me to make this big.
How big were you thinking?
- Like here?
Is that too much?
- [Crowd] Yes!
- Well, I don't have an oven that big
but I will try to-
(Thuy hums)
make it that big.
(Thuy hums and giggles)
What do I need to hit here?
- It needs white chocolate crust.
Extra points, if you
can do extra sprinkles
and then.
- And then what?
- You have to do
the iconic box that it comes in.
- (gasps) Okay well I have a lot of faith
in the art department team.
- Okay, okay.
- I have a lot of work to
do so I will see you later.
- Good luck.
- Thank you. I-
- I can't wait.
to see.
- I need it.
- (giggles) Okay, bye.
- I'll see ya later.
- (giggles) Bye.
- All right guys,
(enchanting music)
let's make it big.
(bells jingling)
Right now I'm about to make
the first layer of the cake.
As you can see there is a lot
of butter for just one layer.
There's actually two layers of this cake.
Whole lot of butter.
Whole lot of sugar.
And again, this is only
one layer of the cake.
The butter gets nice and
combined with the sugar.
(mixer fumbles)
(laughs)
This poor little mixer.
(dreadful music)
I want to just like jump in
and start swimming around in here.
So this is actually 48 egg yolks.
I'm just going to add it in slowly.
Just look at this.
(gasps) I just wish
that you guys could smell this
because this smells really,
really good. (sniffs)
(air exhaling)
A tablespoon of almond extract,
1/2 cup of vanilla extract,
eight cups of milk,
18 cups of flour.
I don't like measurements.
I just kind of like feeling it out.
I just like to measure with my heart.
But I can't, you can't do that in baking.
It's a science so I have to get it right.
(cheerful music)
This is the mold that
we are going to be using
for our first layer of cake.
(grunts)
Okay, let's do this.
I can't see.
(gasps) I hope I'm doing it right.
- [Crowd] Yes.
- Both of these cake layers
are gonna go into the oven
at 300 for two hours.
(joyful music)
(logo swooshes)
And so to make a meringue,
it's egg whites and sugar.
I just need to cook this
until it reaches 160
and then I can use the mixer.
(alarm dings)
Oh my God (gasps), thank you.
I love this.
(joyful music)
(tools clanging)
(Tway sighs)
(joyful music)
Okay.
That looks like a beautiful
batch of meringue.
So I'm gonna add some-
(hand slaps)
butter, duh.
(drums tapping)
I have my vanilla extract
and my almond extract here.
(machine whizzing)
And then more butter.
(drums banging)
Yes.
(trumpet blaring)
Okay, I'm gonna-
(record freezes)
Excuse me.
(techno music)
You gotta keep going, girl.
(dramatic music)
So I'm gonna leave this going.
I'm gonna check on my cakes
because I think they're ready.
(dramatic music)
(frosting splattering)
Making these two giant cakes,
I feel like I can open up a bakery,
maybe call itwickery. (laughs)
(dramatic music)
(hands shuffling)
I'm ready.
I gotta flip this onto here.
Beryl, please help me.
(dramatic music)
(paper ripping)
Okay, ASMR time.
(paper peeling)
Wasn't that so satisfying?
Okay so this is the fun part.
I am going to be cutting out the tree.
(knife scratching)
(twinkling music)
Oh.
(record freezes)
My God, don't cut yourself.
I did cut myself (whimpers).
(dramatic music)
- [Camera Director] Okay,
time for a band-aid.
This just turned into a medical show.
(ambulance blaring)
(dramatic music)
- Do not try this at home.
Yep. And we have a
Little Debbie cake tree.
- [Crowd] Yes.
(joyful music)
- All right, so my cake is in the freezer.
I want it nice and cold for me
to pour the chocolate on top.
So in the meantime, I'm
going to make sprinkles.
I think this is the most satisfying part
of whipping something up
because of the little patterns.
I just kind of like stare at it
and like get in a little trance.
(bright music)
Oh, yes.
Grinch green.
(joyful music)
It's kind of fun.
(machine buzzing)
(joyful music)
Ready?
- [Computer Voice] One, two three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine ten.
(audience clapping)
- A few hours later, my
sprinkles have hardened.
(Tway gasps)
(paper crinkling)
(sprinkles breaking)
Let me taste.
- [Crowd] Oh yeah.
- That tastes like a sprinkle.
A big sprinkle.
(upbeat music)
I gotta work fast.
All right I still have some
more corners to cover over here
and then I'll be ready to decorate.
Finally.
(record scratching)
(upbeat music)
So I'm gonna start off with
sprinkling on my sprinkles.
They're just kind of like everywhere
so I'm going to add them everywhere.
You don't wanna mess up this piping bag.
Consistency is everything.
Yes.
(crowd cheering)
(fingers snapping)
Tway-casso.
(tranquil music)
(claps) Okay.
This is the moment I've
been waiting for all day.
Made the box,
made the cake.
(gasps) I'm ready for the judgment.
Thuy, come on in, please.
(drums tapping)
- Are you ready for me?
- Yes.
(joyful music)
(Tway screams)
- The ca-
Yo. Killed it.
But this is amazing.
(bells jingling)
Oh, it says Tasty Tway.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God that is so cute.
- Okay so one
of the challenges was-
- Yes.
- to make the box.
- Right.
- So?
- Okay, you,
you got the points.
(whistle blows)
- Turn around.
- Okay.
(cheerful music)
Holy.
(laughing)
- Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- To taste this.
- I'm ready, I haven't
had dessert all day.
(both laughing)
So I'm ready.
- We also made extra sprinkles
because you had wanted
the extra sprinkles.
This cake is 50 pounds by the way.
Do you see that crust?
- Oh my God.
Ready?
- Cheers.
(Thuy moaning)
- Tway, this is really good.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you,
- I'm to proud of you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much for challenging me.
This was really, really fun to make.
Let me know what I should make big next
(camera clicking)
and I'll see you next time.
Peace out.
- [Thuy] Love you guys.
(lips smooching)
(bells jingling)
(joyful music)